lebanon has all but collapsed yet the
establishment that plunged the country
into darkness is seeking re-election the
nearly bankrupt state has been
struggling to provide services on
election day it was no different and
it's this status quo that many are
hoping to change
2022 we decide to change so i vote for
somebody not in the political
yeah so
hopefully
will change
but unseating the political class that
has been governing this country for
decades is not easy
anti-establishment coalitions fielded
many candidates the so-called change
forces they are expected to win a few
seats but not to change the political
landscape
i know it's a start for change it's not
the change yet
i hope for the next generation they will
be the chain that process began in late
2019 when massive crowds protested for
months they were met with violence now
many are too disillusioned to even try
the country has been along for long
years the same every four years there's
elections and we think always we can
change but we didn't change
supporters of the former prime minister
assad hadidi think so as well that's why
they are boycotting the vote hariri
headed the muslim sunni community's
largest block in parliament but left
politics earlier this year blaming it on
iran's influence through its ally
hezbollah over the country
in 2005 we won a majority across the
country but we couldn't translate those
gains into anything tangible there is a
gun pointed at our back hezbollah
already controls the country hezbollah
is an armed pro-iranian party that along
with its allies are in the majority in
the outgoing parliament
its opponents mainly pro-western and
pro-saudi parties are hoping to shift
the balance of power
it's a traditional political divide that
has led to bouts of sectarian violence
in the past and breaking through their
grip on power has always been difficult
anti-establishment candidates were
already at a disadvantage before voting
started they're up against powerful
forces a system that works against them
and they're not united which means the
vote is split and it is much harder to
reach the electoral threshold
votes are still being counted but big
changes are unlikely the relatively low
turnout is a sign that the election will
only give what many have described a
corrupt and dysfunctional system a new
lease of life senator al-jazeera beirut